So then it's gonna set it to another payload.
And so you can like, oh, wow, we just found a vulnerability in Kaido.
That's really funny and really cool.
This will definitely be fixed by the time it goes live, but that's hilarious.
I'm actually going to send that right now to the team.
Best part of hacking when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
All right, hackers, here's the deal.
Before you skip forward, give me like two seconds to give you a takeaway.
Okay, here it is.
Threat Lockhart Detect is the best EDR around.
They have a ton of tool integrations.
The alerts are high signal, so you're not swimming in a bunch of garbage.
And both alerting and remediation actions are super customizable.
It's definitely the one you want.
Okay, that's it.
Skip forward if you must.
But I do feel like you should know why I think that, right?
Well, we've talked a lot about the Threat Locker suite, and frankly, they're the best
implemented tools around from a technical perspective.
With this EDR, they're focusing a lot on customization and high signal stuff like
PowerShell activity, log deletion, sketchy RDP sessions, stuff that I have wished many
times EDRs were not detecting actively.
Okay.
And while it does work out of the box, it also gives you the experienced purple teamer, the tools you need to implement custom logic to lock hackers
out of your network at the first sign of trouble.
That trouble is the trouble that you are the most qualified to recognize.
So they're equipping you to deal with it right away.
They're definitely the ones you guys want to go with if you're looking for a new EDR tool.
All right, that's it.
Let's go back to the show.
What's up, hackers?
Got the This Week in Bug Bounty segment for you.
First up is this NullCon Berlin live hacking event that is being run by YesWeHack.
This is just around the corner, September 4th through 5th, and it seems like a really great opportunity.
The way that YesWeHack runs these live hacking events is they reveal the target the day of.
I do have a little piece of insight that it is a big company known all over the world.
So, and it's open to all NullCon participants.
So if you're hitting that up in Germany, then definitely check out the live hacking event with YesWeHack.
Next is also something from YesWeHack, the Bug Bounty Bulletin, which is something
that I wasn't really on my radar until just a week ago.
But apparently it's like pretty big.
It's got like 17,000 subscribers on LinkedIn, and it is YesWeHack's sort of weekly newsletter.
Got some great content in there.
Oh, what is this?
Is this, oh, is this critical thinking?
Oh, how did that get in there?
It's so funny.
No, but this is another great place to get news on Bug Bounty stuff.
So certainly check it out.
They talk about Kaido, a new Kaido video, another live hacking event.
YesWeHack ran.
It's looking like a good roundup.
All right.
Last but not least, we've got Grab with HackerOne.
Grab has been running their program for 10 years.
And as a result, they're doing an anniversary promotion, which is a 2x bounty multiplier from
August 11th to September 10th.
Okay.
So definitely going to want to check that out.
Uh, also just check out the stats for this program.
Three hours to first response, three days to triage, six days to bounty.
That is like S tier response time.
And they're doubling their bounties and they've got a massive scope.
So, uh, this is looking like an amazing program that I've been sleeping on.
You guys should definitely check it out too.
All right.
That's it for the, this week in Bug Bounty.
Let's get back to the show.
Hey guys, welcome back to the critical thinking podcast.
Um, Joseph Reza this time, and I'm interviewing the great Jack Cable and I'll
get into his intro in a minute, but first we'll kick it off with a bug.
Of course, so Jack, um, you just teased it to me and I'm pretty excited about it.
So what bug did you bring for us today?
Awesome.
Well, first of all, thank you so much for having me great to, to be on the podcast.
So, so the one that I've got for today is a fun one, right?
Um, so, um, that this relates to clearly, uh, which imagine that, uh, people, um, might be
familiar with, you know, they, they've gotten a decent amount of attention lately.
Um, and this was maybe a month or so ago, I was, uh, poking around on their desktop app,
uh, found a number of things, which we can probably get into to later, um, around, um,
understanding their, their system prompt, things like that.
But the, the interesting bug was I was looking into, um, essentially saying if there were ways
to compromise the, the desktop application, um, and I saw a few things, right?
Because it's an electron app, um, and they were loading in basically, you know, it essentially
takes a screenshot your computer, sends it off to, to their server, which sends it to open AI or
anthropic, um, and it kind of renders the, the response, uh, from their server as markdown.
Um, so, so that got me interested, right?
Um, and of course, um, with, with electron apps, um, since they're just, you know, websites,
basically, if you can get cross-site scripting, um, that, that, that can be pretty severe.
And, um, the, the interesting thing here is that, um, I noticed one, they weren't using the electron
sandbox, um, and two, um, kind of, I noticed that if you were able to say, get a link to be displayed,
and then the user clicks that opens it up, um, it turns out they were passing quite a bit of, uh, context
to that new website. Um, and, and in particular, there were a number of, uh, post message, um,
handlers available that would essentially, um, receive, um, messages, uh, right from the application.
I think this is probably, um, intended for like internally, right? Because they want to do things
like take screenshots or update different permissions. Um, but what I don't think they
anticipated was that any website that was opened and clearly could access this. And in particular,
probably the, the most dangerous one, right, was the, the function to take a screenshot. So I tested
that out and takes a screenshot of your screen unsurprisingly, but that's pretty bad to give any
arbitrary website the ability to do. Um, so essentially, right. I rigged up that POC where I
just continually took a screenshot of, uh, the person's computer. Um, so effectively you're now
recording their screen and all they have to do is, um, click a link. Um, so what you should have done
is given that to Amazon. So when anyone was using clearly in interviews, it was actually monitoring
the interviewee screen, right? It's like, it's like a reverse clue. They think they're getting away with
cheating on the, uh, interview, but actually Amazon's just monitoring their screen the whole time.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly. You're, you're the one who's being recorded instead.
Right. Um, so, so, so yeah, that was a fun one. Um, I, uh, disclosed it to them. They did, uh, fix it,
uh, quickly. Did any of the post message allow for XSS? Because where it's an electron app,
that could have just been RCE, right? So, so yeah, I was also looking for access. I can't talk XSS or,
um, things like whether kind of input from that would go into a system command, uh, beyond that there,
there wasn't a ton of attack service. There were, um, functions, for instance, like request microphone
access, things like that, but no thing that necessarily took in input, um, yeah. But still,
I mean, pretty bad screenshots of the, of the desktop is basically leaking any secrets and
anything else. So that's cool. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Sweet dude. Good find. Well,
I will now intro you, um, since you're appropriately christened here. Um, yeah. So, uh, for anybody who
doesn't know who Jack Cable is, he was a very top bug hunter. I think he has like 10,000 rep on hacker one.
And, um, was kind of around the live hacking scene and stuff for a little bit, but has since,
uh, started a company called corridor.dev. Did you do anything in between those two things?
Like, was that, did you have any, like, uh, do you have a company before corridor?
So, so I was actually working in government, uh, before this, and that was a lot of the reason,
you know, that I, um, stopped doing bug bounty as much because as it turns out, when you're working
in government, you, you can't really get income from, um, outside sources. Um, so spent a couple of years
was, um, working in the, um, Senate for, for one year writing, um, legislation around, um, things
like open source software security. And then what was at, um, CISA cybersecurity and infrastructure
security agency for, for two years, uh, leading on the, the, the secure by design initiative.
So it did a lot to try to get tech companies to, to improve that their software security.
Yeah. Yeah. That's awesome. Did, did being involved deeper than any of the rest of us are
make you more hopeful or kind of like, uh, less helpful for a positive change in that way? Like,
do you think that being a part of government and then also even more than just being a part of like,
you know, a specific agency, but like also just being involved in the legislation process,
was that like disheartening or was it actually like not that bad?
Um, so, so, uh, I think there, there's some of both, right? Where the time I was, um, in the Senate,
for instance, uh, was, uh, a very productive time kind of around cybersecurity legislation. There, there
was a lot of bipartisan support that there still is some today, but, but, um, it may be a little less
so, um, and so, so it saw a lot of kind of positive momentum, um, and likewise being at CISA found that
when you're in the right place in government, kind of when appropriately empowered, there's a lot that
can be done. Um, so it did a bunch of work to, um, get commitments from, from companies, for instance,
to improve their product security. One of the elements, for instance, this was the, the secure by design
pledge was to, um, operate a vulnerability disclosure policy. Um, so, so, um, tried to really kind of
strengthen the role of security research. Um, so, so I think there are opportunities to, to have, um,
some large scale impact here. Of course, change doesn't happen overnight. Uh, but, but I do think
it's important for, for, you know, um, technical people to, to be in the room because ultimately-
Oh yeah. 100%.
Yeah. You, you, you need to understand how things work under the hood.
What is that like VDP or VR, or VRP thing that Casey Ellis kind of started?
Did, um, any of the work you- Disclose.io?
Yeah. Was that, uh, at all like an inspiration or useful to you guys in that whole-
Certainly.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So, so now I, I got involved with, with Disclose.io, um, a, a while ago,
uh, when it was starting out. Um, and, and I, I think definitely a lot of that, that momentum
kind of helped to, to underpin a lot of, a lot of the work that got done, where, you know, now we're
in a point where it is really the, the norm to operate a vulnerability disclosure policy, right?
That's sort of the bare minimum for, for a company who wants to be responsible around security. Of course,
even better to, to go incentivize research with a bug bounty. Um, but at the, the baseline, you,
you need to have a way to, to take in reports from hackers and a lot of the work that Casey and I
did as well as around advocating for legal safe harbor to, uh, get, give these assurances that a
company won't, uh, take, um, legal action against you. Um, so, so, so that work, what was really
essential and, um, yeah, a lot of what I focused on government, right, was kind of helping to, to
continue to, to make this the, the, the norm, um, and making the expectation that that companies
would, um, like that, that that's in the pledge language is also to have safe harbor within their
vulnerability disclosure policy, um, to basically reduce friction there to deploy it a lot like
easier or cause no company's going to do it. If it's a heavy lift to actually like, you know,
put those terms and those agreement out there, but if it's like a one click or like a, here,
just put this on your website, then all of a sudden it becomes really feasible. Right.
Exactly. Exactly. Cool. Well, one thing I wanted to do was like talk kind of practically about AI
stuff, obviously. Um, it's kind of. What people expect me to talk about, but it's also what I love
and I find enjoyable. So what, at what point, well, I guess kind of two things. One, I was going to see
when it, when did it click for you or when did like, what kind of opened your eyes or made you find
kind of AI app sec more interesting and then to like, you know, what have you been doing in that
field or kind of pressing into, and obviously court.dev has a little bit of that to say there,
but let's start with that first question. What, what exactly got you, where are you like, wow,
what was the eye opening kind of moment for the mixture of AI and security, whether it's from the
offensive side of things or the defensive side of things? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, for, for me,
it was really twofold. So, so one, um, and through the course of the, the work at CISA, right. As well
as, uh, just my time doing bug bounties saw just how much companies were struggling with product
security. And as you know, right. Often it's the very basic vulnerabilities that slipped through and
cause a lot of impact, cause a lot of harm. Um, and kind of just got me thinking, okay, there has to be a
better way. Um, and, and then really what, what I think kind of made, made me realize there's a lot,
a lot of opportunity here was just using the, these tools for development. So using cursor, um,
quad code, some other tools and seeing kind of just how capable they are. Um, of course they're, they're,
they, they all have their limitations, but like as a software developer, these tools have helped
me work out of five, 10 times as fast. And kind of if I try to, you know, go code something without,
um, one of these tools now, I'm just going to be so much slower. Um, so, so it kind of got me thinking,
okay, if AI is this good at understanding code, writing code, um, it, it must be quite capable as well
around, um, aspects like vulnerability discovery, as well as other, uh, workflows within, um, application
security. Um, so that was kind of the starting point. Yeah. I made that same leap in my head,
but I don't know if that was intuitively true or like, I don't know if it was intuitive to everyone
else when that first kind of popped off. Right. Like it makes complete sense, but it is kind of
interesting how like the theory of mind works for, uh, humans versus like, uh, like people who are
familiar and intimate kind of with like, um, LLMs today and what they're expecting that other LLMs
would be capable of, even just like the theory of mind of a brain that's working off of tokens
instead of like our brains, which can see both words or characters and can like parse them both
independently and uniquely and how LLMs kind of parse things via tokens. And like being able to have
theory of theory of mind for what the AI might see with like how it's viewing the world in tokens,
instead of viewing it with characters versus words is like very interesting to me. And so I think that's
kind of like a similar thing you did there where you basically understood that, Hey, if this thing's
good at development, it's also processed all the PRs and all the security fixes across all of GitHub as
well. So it probably also knows what vulnerabilities look like and how to exploit them and that sort of
thing. Um, yeah, so that's cool. And so then like, what do you, what exactly are you all building with
corridor.dev? Yeah. So, so really the, the focus with corridor, right. Is building, um, kind of applying
AI to help, um, product security teams. Um, and I I'd say it's really a full range of, of the, the, the work
that they do. So, so it's both around kind of better enabling vulnerability discovery, um, and really
building up the, the kind of context of a code base. Uh, but, but then it's tying this into kind of every
stage of the development process. Um, so, so we talked to product security teams who almost, you know,
universally are overwhelmed. They have too much work to do. Um, their existing like stack analysis tools
are surfacing, I don't know, like 90% plus false positives. They don't have time to go through those.
Developers don't have time. Um, and they're also missing the, the vulnerabilities that, that actually
matter. Um, so, so what we're focusing on is really enabling these product security teams to, to
multiply their work, just like, you know, curse or other tools have totally changed the game of software
development, but in many ways it feels like security teams are still living in the past with their tooling.
Um, so, so, so it's around capitalizing on these advancements to, um, kind of help product security
teams review every pull request, be able to, um, take all the, you know, bug bounty reports that they're
getting, act on them more quickly. Those sorts of, of workflows that I think are, are really underexplored.
Yeah. Yeah. That's awesome. When you were doing, uh, bug bounty, what was kind of your bread and butter?
What type of vulnerabilities were you like typically finding more of versus the other ones?
So, so yeah, it was a mix. I think probably the most interesting, most frequent ones were, were,
were authorization vulnerabilities. And you know, some of them can be quite simple IDORs where you just
change an ID and it gives you all sorts of, um, sensitive information. Others could be kind of a
little more, uh, kind of complicated business logic things. But I think those were really some of the,
the more impactful, uh, vulnerabilities that I reported over the years. Um, and there are some,
some interesting ones too. Kind of like right when I was getting into, to bug bounties,
this is when I was like 15 or 16, on some of the kind of initial things I was looking for were race
conditions. Um, and, and did this especially on like cryptocurrency websites where it would basically
go to everyone and see, okay, can I like withdraw money multiple times? Can I, um, kind of do other
actions that will allow me to, um, basically, yes, um, steal money if I want to and found a number of those
vulnerabilities that I disclosed? There was one exchange where I think like I could have drained their
wallet of like a hundred K or something in Bitcoin if I had wanted to. Um, so a lot of those types of
flaws that, I mean, you know, might, um, can't go missed without, uh, more extensive testing.
Yeah. That's interesting. Cause that was back before, um, the BERT plugin for race condition specific
tests, right? Like the last time I could attack it was before that. Yeah. Do you remember how you were doing it?
Yeah. I mean, I, and I, I still do this and where it works a good amount of the time, basically just,
um, you know, doing BERT copy as curl and then opening a terminal, sending off, uh, multiple requests
in parallel. Um, so I'm sure yet doesn't, that's all the things that the, yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah.
The BERT extension probably has a better detection rate, but at least for a lot of these things where,
you know, it's not, uh, um, like instantaneous operation, um, it can do quite well. Yeah. I think
I, this is like when I was like 15, I read this blog post of someone who'd done this in like Starbucks
or something. And then I was like, wow, I should really start testing this out. And it worked quite
a bit. There's so many cool little small bug classes like race conditions or like, um,
the most recent episode that just aired, uh, today, as we're recording this, uh, July 24th,
uh, Justin interviewed Matias and he, um, it's all about archive attacks. I don't know if you,
if you saw it in your feed yet, but it's like really neat. It's basically like a bunch of,
you know, variations of the old, like, uh, zip slip attacks, but, um, you know, just new variations of
it. And, you know, obviously pretty big impact. It's neat the way that there are so many like little
tiny niches. Um, cool. Yeah. So coming back to the quarter to depth thing, one thing that I thought
was interesting was I think you tweeted or saw about it and that, um, no, no, it was actually in one of
your congressional speaking things. You're basically like, you know, AI is going to write, you know,
plenty of vulnerabilities. And I found that to definitely be true in my kind of, uh,
vibe coding in the last few months, but I'm also like, yeah, but so are plenty of like novice developers,
right? Like, uh, before vibe coding bug bounty was lucrative because humans write lots of
vulnerabilities. And so like, it doesn't change the game too much. Like it's like, um, it's almost
independent of AI writing vulnerabilities that AI project would actually be useful. Right. It's like,
even if we didn't have vibe coding, this would still be a very high utility tool.
Yeah. Yeah. So, so to me, what, what's really interesting, right. Is that a lot of how I think
about it is in terms of volume and scale. And we, we know that the, these AI development tools are
allowing developers to write code much faster than ever before, much higher volumes. We also know
that's enabling people who have never code before to go in, you know, vibe code, a website or something like
that. Um, so, so, so I think it does to your point, um, just continue expanding the attack surface, uh,
where, where I'm less worried about, you know, novel vulnerabilities getting introduced from a vibe code
app, but it's more about, okay, these, um, models are going to introduce that the same types of flaws
that we've known about for decades that humans haven't been able to root out, um, that, that are going to
continue to give us problems. Um, and I, the, the chance to, to, uh, testify to Congress, this was maybe
a month or two ago, um, at Stanford, um, and, and a lot of the, the focus was around how, how AI was
affecting security. I love the things I mentioned there is there's this benchmark called BaxBench,
which looks at, um, how well LLMs do at writing secure code. Um, and, and it found maybe unsurprisingly
that even the best models about 20 to 30% of the time, uh, do introduce vulnerabilities, uh, right.
And they can, can, can often can be, you know, basic things like SQL injections, excess I've had,
like when using models myself, it's like, adds a command injection vulnerability or something. And
if you tell it like, okay, write a secure command execution, then it'll, um, do it securely,
but, but otherwise it won't. Um, so, so it's things like that, that these models are introducing,
and especially when it gets to, to things like business logic flaws, I, I think that's where a lot
of the, you know, vulnerabilities in, in vibe code apps that, that we'll see will originate, uh, because
again, that, that requires kind of the, the person who's behind the wheel, who's using these tools to
actually understand that the security model, um, and as we, we allow people with, with less than less
experience to, to build these apps. I think the, the kind of, yeah, uh, attack surface is just gonna
kind of continue to, to balloon. Yeah. Same, same kind of story there for,
you know, human like coders, or I guess what I'm trying to think, what I'm trying to say is like,
you know, big companies with big budgets have had static code analysis tools for a long time,
right? It's gonna find the places where you might have code injection or where you might have,
um, XSS or you might have a SQL injection, but the business logic flaws and, you know, um, permission
issues like RBAC permission issues are just like never going to be found by static analysis or probably
even like lots of times from code review, because it just requires the app to actually be running to
test a lot of those things. Right. Um, so yeah, that's really interesting. Uh, and I, and I actually think that
the, the very final form there, um, will hopefully be eventually be solved by hack bots. Right. Because
it really does need to have like live testing on top of something like corridor or what I don't
understand why this hasn't existed yet. I hope with the GitHub release and GitHub spark this week
that they'll eventually release it. But I don't understand why GitHub doesn't have automatic security
PR reviews. It's just like, it's right for the taking it's right there. I would pay a subscription for
every company would if like every PR you put out just had an automated security, like, like, uh, uh,
wow. What's it called code review? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. That. And that's something
we've been doing and found that can work quite well. Um, and to your point, like, yeah, I think,
um, like, especially when it comes to, to authorization type bugs, that that's not something you're going to
be able to find with like static analysis. It's something that you need to actually understand
how the, the application works and operates. Um, and like, you see this a lot with these, like,
you know, zero code five coded sites. A lot of them use like Supabase or Firebase for the database
and have like pretty secure configurations, but the, the aspect that can go wrong, right? That you can't
just like tell hard code or kind of, yeah, prevent that by default is when it comes to permissions.
Cause like with Supabase, for instance, you need to define authorization policies for who can access
what, um, and, and kind of securely doing that is not a, a trivial problem. So, so it's, it's areas like
that, that I think are really going to be the, the long tail that, um, to your point, um, AI can,
can help us to, to understand how an application works. But, um, like, I think as you know, the,
the, if there's, I think, yeah, you know, one, one security that it's, that as the amount of code grows,
as the complexity of code grows, that the number of vulnerabilities, um, it increases, uh, by, uh,
quite a bit. So I think we'll, we'll, we'll just see more of that. Yeah. And honestly, like that's,
I had never thought about this before, but the fact that vibe coding kind of breaks down at a certain
size is like a good thing for security right now, because it's still manageable to kind of code review
it and to like find those little vulnerabilities whenever it can go slightly longer horizon. Like
if you were like to let, for example, Gemini two, five pro output, you know, a 500,000 token app,
like the chance of vulnerabilities is way higher. Like you said, because the more complexity and the
more code, the more likely there are to be vulnerabilities. And so, and these coding systems
are going to keep improving, right? It's right now, it's the worst it'll ever be as they always say.
So as these systems in the next year or two ramp up to being able to build much more complex app,
there's going to be many more vulnerabilities. The other thing I thought about that you mentioned
on the permissioning thing with Supabase, because I do think that's a big deal is, do you know if
Supabase is able to be deployed via like Terraform in the same way you can do like GitHub repos
such that you can manage permissions with like configuration files? Because like, you know,
when you're adding new members to a new organization and get up or whatever, if you've got it all deployed
via Terraform or something, you can like actually manage those permissions in the file. And I think that
would make LLMs much better than them having to use the UI or UX, right? Of Supabase.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think that is what many of these like VibeCoding tools are doing is that they'll
generate like a kind of, a lot of them are using Supabases like row level security kind of
configurations. And they do have a file that contains the essentially authorization policies
for your code base. So certainly, yeah, I think, you know, having these configuration files is a good
thing, but what really matters is, okay, are the contents of them actually kind of lining up with
the security model of the application. And to your point, the bigger the code base grows, the more
potential for missteps there. I've noticed that my apps, whenever I'm letting an LLM develop them,
often get insecure when I'm struggling with something that is usability, which is kind of funny because it's
that tension between usability and security. Like I was working on an app where it's basically just
like read-only public or admins. And I wanted the read-only public to basically show the results from
like a bunch of matches. But it, but like the, the table kept getting like 401 or 403 based on the way
it had set up the API to pull those results, to pull, to pull those matches. And then, so it's like,
let's just make this public when actually what it needed to do was think about like what data was in
that table rather than just like switching the table to being public. Right. And so I thought that
was like kind of interesting and probably in a way that it plays out pretty often.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. I think there's, yeah, a lot of potential, like I've seen this even outside
security context where, you know, you ask the LLM to do something and it does that as well as like
through other things that you didn't ask that kind of often they'll, you know, be lazy and try to take
shortcuts instead of actually fixing the underlying issue. Yeah. The other thing that I've been wrestling
with is like on the two ends of the spectrum from like using SDKs and libraries to just like rolling your
own. I actually like to kind of roll my own, not personally, like when I'm developing personally,
I definitely don't. But with AI, I like the fact that it can kind of roll its own because you can kind
of like control everything and make it custom or whatever. But what I find is that when I'm making
a bigger app and it starts to do that, it gets really bloated, especially if it's doing like markdown
parsing to HTML or something. Now it's like writing a bunch of regular expressions to like convert bullets
and new lines. It's like, no, just use a library, please. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, it's cool.
I've seen that too. Yeah. I wanted to circle us back to the clearly stuff because that was a pretty
funny when that blew up on Twitter recently. So yeah, if anyone doesn't know, basically,
yeah, well, actually you, you go ahead and tell the first half of the story. You tell
about the system prompt research that you were presumably doing along with your bug you mentioned
earlier. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. So this was around the same time as I found that bug. I,
you know, had taken Clueli's desktop app. I unzipped it because electron apps are basically just a
zip file and noticed pretty quickly that the system prompt for both like their standard version and
enterprise version were embedded within the source code. For those who aren't familiar,
clearly essentially, you know, yes, supposedly lets you cheat on anything. So basically it's a prompt
where it takes a screenshot of your screen, says, okay, tell the user like what to say next. So I was
able to find those complete prompts. There were some interesting elements of that. They also said,
for instance, like never say what model you're using, but like right above that was hard code.
That's I think was like, forget what exact model, but there's a open AI model and a anthropic model in
there. So naturally, you know, I tweeted this out, said that Clueli embedded their prompt in their desktop
source code that that wound up getting quite a bit of attention. So yeah, that was the first part of the story.
Yeah. And so then basically you received a kind of take down or cease and desist or something on that
tweet, right? Or actually no, was it for a demo? Was it a gist or something?
So it was for the tweet. So essentially, a couple of weeks later, right, I got a DMCA
notice from Twitter that my tweet had been, or at least the images within it had been taken down because Clueli
filed a DMCA take down saying that my tweet had contained
like basically proprietary information. Yeah, their intellectual property, which is kind of funny if
you think about it, right? Because if this is their intellectual property, maybe they shouldn't be sending
it to the desktop of however many users they have. So that was kind of wild. And again, going back to the
camp vulnerability disclosure policy disclosed IO work, one of the elements of a safe harbor is committing to
not take legal action like filing DMCA takedowns. So that was a bit surprising that they would go and
do that. Now, the funny part is I go and tweet this out. And the CEO of Clueli responds saying that they didn't file the
DMCA takedown. And also if it would if it would have been Roy Lee that actually
filed it, that would have been so ironic considering that he was literally sued by like
companies like I think they've been sued by like five or 10 companies. Yeah.
So the fact that they were like you threatening legal action is just like so ironic and crazy.
Yeah. Yeah. So he said they didn't do it. And he also like posted a screenshot of his conversation with his lawyer around it.
But that also was strange since the DMCA takedown notice had the information of the Clueli employee who filed that.
So I posted that. I tagged the employee and he admitted, you can see it on Twitter, that he had done this, that he apologized, that he didn't check with Clueli leadership.
And then Roy also apologized after that. The funny part is that, yeah, he retracted it, though the tweets are still down.
The images are still been restored.
So working on that. But the other fun part is that Roy had offered to compensate me.
I said, how about instead you donate to the EFF?
So he wound up donating about a thousand dollars to the EFFs, at least something.
That's cool. Yeah, that's really cool. Good on him.
I yeah, I was messaging him initially when they first like kind of got started and stuff.
And we were we were messing a little bit, but I don't think that he likes me too much anymore.
I basically was just like sharing some other vulnerabilities they had at the very beginning.
And he was like, no, no, no, it's not vulnerable.
And then when it came out, it was super vulnerable.
I was like, I told you so. And then he hated that.
So but anyways, yeah, that's funny and cool.
And I think that if anything, they probably viewed that as like free media attention
with the way that they run their company.
So I don't think that he is actually bothered at all.
Yeah. Cool.
Yes, I do think you would maybe be a good person to talk about this.
This is a little bit of a hot take.
I personally don't think that there's a lot of risk these days for a known bug hunter
to hack on things that they do not have permission to hack on.
And from being on the legislative side and working at CISA and also being like a reasonable, ethical, moral person.
I would be interested in your thoughts on that.
And I think we can kind of break this down into two categories.
One is, let's say, testing with your own account.
So I know because of that, like Supreme Court's recommendation, I think testing with your own
accounts is like most people think that that actually is probably fine, or at least the people that I kind
of talked to about this and then and then let's say another situation where like you don't have two
accounts and you can't get two accounts because it's like tied to your identity or something.
And you still want to vet the application for your own usage.
So it is still well, then maybe there's three categories.
Sorry to make this confusing.
So one is you're testing an app that you're using and you have two users and you only test your users you own.
Two is you're testing an app that you do actually use and you can claim that you're like actually
wanting to test it for your own usage, for example, but you don't have a second account
and you want to check for things like, you know, that would disclose other people's information
like ID or whatever else.
And then the third category will say is apps that you actually don't use and you have no
right to be testing on.
So like you're trying to hack F1 or, you know, you're trying to hack the NBA, right?
Like, but they don't have bug bounty programs or VDPs.
And so I still, you know, I don't do it.
I have a wife and three children and, you know, my risk tolerance is low, so I don't do it.
But I still talk to people and I basically tell people that I think that the real true risk
of legislation coming, if you're willing to disclose whatever you find responsibly,
is basically infinite, like approaching zero these days, especially if you have a reputation
with the, you know, bug bounty platforms or whatever.
So give me your take on those three, on those three things.
So, yeah, yeah.
Super interesting topic.
And of course, I'll start this by saying I'm not a lawyer.
Please don't take this as legal advice.
So the current state of things.
So one, in terms of what is legally okay,
it is one, if you are testing something that you have locally.
So for instance, like in this clearly scenario, right, this was their desktop application.
I was testing on my computer in the past, like decades ago, companies would bring, you know,
kind of legal action under say DMCA against researchers saying you didn't have the right to reverse engineer
that program or that program.
We now have, there's a security research exemption in the DMCA.
So if you're doing good faith security research, then you are allowed to, to test something locally.
Now, where it does get a lot fuzzier is when that application isn't, you know, hosted on yourselves,
but it's someone else's application.
So if it's client-side JavaScript,
are you like, I guess, technically allowed to probably look at that part,
but you can't test for server-side volumes or something?
Like if you're reading letter of the law.
Yeah, yeah, you can essentially, you know, reverse engineer the client-side JavaScript or like desktop
application, or if you get, I don't know, like the binary of an application or something like that.
Where it gets fuzzier in the US is the, so the Computer for Unabuse Act, CFA, says essentially any
unauthorized access to a computer system is illegal, unless you have permission,
specific permission to test it.
And that's where, again, right, having a VDP or bug bounty program, which proactively is a company
saying, hey, we want you to test this. Here are the rules that you can follow. Ideally, they'll have
a safe harbor to say, we commit to not taking legal action. But that's the reason that's so important,
right, is that's providing authorization for you to go and test a system. In the absence of that,
right, in your examples, technically anything that you do could be considered to be unauthorized access and
violating CFA. Now, to your point, like if you are testing on your own account, if you find something,
if you responsibly disclose it, it's unlikely that a company would choose to take legal action against
you. But it's always a possibility. And like I've experienced in my own instances, you know, outside
of clearly where there have been investigations and fortunately haven't had anything happen. But I do
think there are still risks. Unfortunately, that's why I think it is really positive that we have so many
more companies having VDPs. I've also done a bunch of work to get state governments to operate on
vulnerability disclosure policies, federal government. Now, every federal agency has one. So we're making a
lot of good progress. And then we also have the Department of Justice a couple of years ago put out
an updated sentencing policy to say essentially they wouldn't sentence people for CFA violations. Where are
they demons? Good faith, security research. So we're in a bit of a better place. But I think still a lot of
work to be done to make this something that you can, you know, truly go and do good faith, security
research without having to worry at all about legal action. Yeah. Yeah, that's interesting. So you're
saying that you actually do think there is more legal action brought against people or at least
threatened legal action against people than maybe gets publicized because I basically never see it.
I think so. It's not like I'm not saying it's super common, but personally, I've experienced it. I know
some other friends who have. And right, even if like, I mean, even the samples of you and some friends
would be enough to convince me that it were common because. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And even short of, you
know, like actually getting sentenced or convicted of a crime, there's all sorts of kind of things that go
into to the legal cases and lawyers are notorious for not being cheap. So yeah, I think it is still a real
consideration. Certainly we're better off now than we were five, 10, 15, 20 years ago. But I think
there's certainly room to go. Yeah. Cool. Sweet. Are you going to be at DEF CON?
I will be. Yeah. Yeah. Excited to be heading back there. We're going to be sponsoring B-Sides this
year and then I'll be hanging out around DEF CON as well. Nice, dude. Well, I don't typically do this
since we're not too late on time at all. Do you have any like thoughts or questions for me or any like
kind of just, you know, we were talking before we kind of started here. We're both joining like a kind
of a smaller potential contract base, like red team thing. Is there any red team topics or anything
that's interesting to you that you've kind of heard about or thought about lately? I mean, I'd love to
hear just like how you've been using AI in your own testing. Like what have you found most effective?
What's your day to day workflow? Cool. Yeah. I think this episode will go out late enough where
this is fine to talk about. And if it, yeah, based on our content calendar for the pod, it looks like
it'll go out maybe plenty late. Yeah. 139. Okay, cool. Yeah. So this will, this will definitely be out by
then. So I can definitely share this. So me and Justin and Bebix have been working in Kaido. You know,
you probably heard of our app shift, which was fine. It didn't do, you know, crazy well or anything,
but you know, Kaido wanted to, you know, really take on more of like an AI perspective. And so
there is a really cool shift agents thing that we're dropping that I will share my screen about.
Let me find a safe project. Actually, let me just make a new temp project. But what it is is,
and Justin's been talking about this for a while. It's called shift agents. So I will start a new
project project, test, create. All right. Yeah. So check this out. I'm sorry for audio listeners.
I'll describe what I'm doing. Okay. In case you're watching, but where's the share button? Here it is.
So share screen window, Kaido. So in Kaido, basically there's going to be the thing called
shift agents. And what's really cool is we have some built-in system prompts for things like XSS
testing, SSRF testing, passversal SQL injection, and then you can add custom prompts here. And how these
are used by the agents is really cool. So let's say you send this request to replay. And here in replay,
you want to like test for XSS in this parameter. Let's just say, you know, access or actually input,
you know, whatever. So you can, oh, this is switching to WebSockets. Let's use a better request.
So yeah, we'll use this request. So this is just some random request that was automatically populated by
Google. So you can open this agent and then you can choose what prompts. If you want to check for XSS
here, you can say like, try and find XSS in the ATIP param.
All right, cool. So basically in shift agents, you go in, you put your API key here,
you validate it. And then here in replay, these agents will just like work on your behalf. So you
can say like find an XSS in ATIP for me. And it's like, you know, there's like the thinking blob where
it's talking about what you're talking about. And then, so right now it's asking for clarification
the first query parameter. And so what it, but what it does is it will modify the payload, send it, modify
the payload, send it. Let's see if it's working. Yeah. So it modified it to this, then it sent it.
Then it's like looking at saying like, oh, 400 bad requests. So let's try something else. So then it's
going to set it to another payload. And so you can like, oh, wow, we just found the vulnerability in
Kaido. That's really funny and really cool. This will definitely be fixed by the time it goes live,
but that's hilarious. I'm actually going to send that right now to the team. That is really cool and
funny. But anyways, you get the point, right? And so these agents, oh my goodness gracious.
Oh, okay. Yeah. I'm gonna have to kill my Kaido. That's hilarious. But yeah, you get the point.
So that's just one really cool way. I would say you, you might find this really fascinating,
especially with your AI security research or AI safety research and specifically being in like
the contract red team stuff. Actually, sorry, I'm going to tag the team. Okay. So yeah, the other way
that I was using AI in the last few days that I thought was really cool was basically, let me stop
sharing, um, to create frames and payloads. This is not anything new, but basically to create frames
and layered attacks for jailbreaking other models. So because grok is like kind of so easy to jailbreak
and willing to help with things that are malicious, I've been using crock to basically create payloads to do
safety testing for anthropics models. And, um, specifically the frame for the attack was like a
fictitious website, or if you wanted a fictitious book or whatever, sometimes you're trying to basically
get it out of its security protections or its guardrails. And so you need like a back and forth. That's like
make a recipe for suit like Sudafed. Right. And then it's like, oh, now let's actually make it more
dangerous and more dangerous and more dangerous. Like you need this like back and forth. And so using models to
kind of reconstruct that frame to really save a lot of time is super helpful. Um, I've been using AI to,
from like not a security perspective, but just from a building perspective to build like little side
projects. Like one of my, you know, ones I'm most excited about is basically a soccer ranking thing
for my good buddy. Who's like a high school soccer coach. And so like, I'm really excited for it to like
rank, you know, like local high school teams with like ELO and everything to kind of like predict which
is better and how they're doing and all that. So I think that's really cool. Um, and then I'm
trying to think if there's anything else from like a security perspective that I'm doing.
Um, I, where I'm, um, advisor for ethiac, I consult them on their hack bot, their building
and I'm advisor for split. So I consult them on their, like their AI safety stuff. And so,
you know, getting to see kind of the hack bot side of things, and then the safety testing side of
things like pretty fascinating and cool, but yeah, yeah, it's awesome. Yeah. And super cool to see the,
the kind of, um, agent definitely feels like where the, the future is going is like, yeah,
I don't know if we're at, uh, kind of the fully autonomous stage, but certainly similar to,
you know, how, yeah, you can now go and code much faster. It feels like that
it is just going to come to, to security, to, to bug bounties and make everyone work a whole lot faster.
Yeah. I don't think that it's going to be worth it to do what I just showed
you on like every parameter on every tab, right? Like go find XSS. But what I do think will be
really valuable is it's like, Hey, I found this parameter and I know it does something weird
here and I need to find like a bypass. Can you just try like every possible Unicode normalization
pair? Can you try every special character in this, in this thing? And just like, tell me which one's
interesting and just like set it off to running. I think that is where it will really pay off, um,
in the short term. And then, you know, maybe long-term we'll get something more like an autonomous
hack bot. Um, but yeah. And one thing that I think is really cool about Kaido actually,
this will be coming out sometime in a month or two. So this is like something that's worth
thinking about. I'm sure you saw, um, open AI just released their new agent thing. I actually just
got access today. I haven't played with it yet, but that along with all these other companies are
basically building browser use. And what's really neat about Kaido, which is not true for Burp,
is that it is a website, right? But it's like basically a little web server. And so you can,
you can just tell these agents, like, especially if they're like local ones. So, um, if you're,
you know, what's the new one, it's, um, perplexity comment or the dia browser. Like if you're using
browser use stuff like that, and these models are going to keep getting better at browser use,
um, to use your, you know, use your own computer or whatever, set up something you can have Kaido,
just like boot it up and these models can actually browse around in Kaido to do things. So you could,
you know, have it actually take actions in Kaido to help you hack or to like set up some sort of
hacking thing or whatever. So I think that's pretty cool. And a reason why I'm excited to be an advisor
for Kaido. Uh, cause I do think them being browser based is actually going to be a huge key differentiator.
So yeah, yeah, it's super exciting. Cool dude. Well, we really appreciate you coming on the pod and I look
forward to seeing you at Defcon and for anyone listening to this, um, uh, heed Jack's words on what
you shouldn't shouldn't hack and go, uh, go promote your, your local governments, but also your company's,
uh, VDP or VRP program if they don't have one. So cheers.
Exactly. Well, yeah.
Oh, actually where can people find you, Jack? Yeah. Where can people find you?
Awesome. Yeah. I'm on, you know, Twitter, Jack H cable, LinkedIn as well. Um, so, and yeah,
I'll be around Defcon as well. Awesome. Thanks. See ya. Peace.
Thank you. And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking. Thanks so much for watching
to the end y'all. If you want more critical thinking content, uh, or if you want to support
the show, head over to ctbb.show/discord. You can hop in the community. There's lots of great
high level hacking discussion happening there on top of masterclasses, hack alongs,
exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild. If you're a full-time hunter, it's a great time.
Trust me. I'll see you there.